ghost birthday month and I know someone
plays Bingo here do you have any fun
Bingo memories I do play one time I
almost won fifteen thousand dollars
playing bingo on Valentine's Day with my
mom I'll never forget I needed B12 and
they they literally called 9 10 11 13
and I didn't win it and I'm still upset
over it oh my gosh I never will look at
the vitamin the same way
Rocky will have better luck she's out of
Arizona Charlie's where you can make
your own Bingo memories let's check back
in with her and see all the live action
how's it going
Jillian I'm sorry to hear that okay
you're gonna have to come on down to
Arizona Charlie's to redeem yourself
okay because we're winning money in here
there's been about 12 winners so far
since the game started at three yes 12
winners and it's just so satisfying even
when you hear someone else say bingo
some people get mad okay yeah it gets
serious how how crazy does it get in
here obviously this is the afternoon
game this is kind of mellow but does it
get to get back in just a lot of energy
yes we do have sessions where we have a
lot of energy when we have our vgk
nights with a lot of energy going on
there speaking of bgk nights did you
know you can get a custom dopper am I
saying that right dopper here tell
everybody what this means so you can get
vgk daubers we do veggie GK nights and
then we are actually giving away a vgk
suite for a game in January that's very
cool this is all part of the national
Bingo month celebration and what more
are we looking forward to I hear there's
a tournament coming up yes a tournament
from December 12th through the 18th
where you can win almost a quarter
million dollars
okay so obviously besides you know the
money how do you think these people in
here and I just love the crowd in here
it's so diverse you've got people on
dates you got people just hanging in
getting their self-care on and here
playing trying to win some money but
what how do you think it benefits the
players besides the money
it's home that's the only way I can sum
it up is that it's home that's great I
love that Jordan you've been here 17
years so you know you are the queen here
at the at the bingo Banquet Hall here at
Arizona Charlie's this is where you come
and you win money you have fun and it's
National Bingo month so there's no
better time to do it but but now but
this is all year round for you guys
exactly all year round we do this every
day from 9 to 11. and all you gotta do
is come in and pay four dollars to play
that's it okay so come on down Arizona
Charlie's and we'll be right back